well the city of Henderson is expanding
with the goal of taking over the Fiesta
hotel and casino Mary Jane billiesza
takes us to West Lake Mead Parkway and
the 95 sharing what will become one of
the Station Casino properties
a new development for Henderson as the
city has plans to acquire the former
Fiesta site with plans to create a new
sports facility Jared Smith the director
of Economic Development and Tourism says
the city of Henderson is looking to
specifically provide a youth sports
center this would be an indoor community
Sports Hub where kids can play
basketball soccer volleyball and much
more located on East Lake Mead Parkway
it would be easy access for downtown and
Eastside residents Not only would
families benefit from a space like this
but it could also bring in plenty of
Tourism with national tournaments and
traveling leagues as we decide what the
center is going to look like and what
sports are going to be there we're going
to be actively engaging the community
and what types of facilities or what
types of amenities in these facilities
are are you looking for that you feel
would be valuable and not just inside
the facility but for the remainder of
the property as well we hope to really
bring back some amenities that we lost
with the fiesta being torn down the
purchasing price is 32 million dollars
for the acquisition and Smith says the
vision process for this project will
start early next year
now while there are potential plans for
Fiesta Henderson no plans announced
right now for the shuttered Fiesta
Rancho and Texas Station on Rancho and
Lake Mead that's in North Las Vegas